Since I grew up in a Christian home, the Christian story always made sense to me.
My parents have worked their entire lives with a professional Christian ministry.
My dad has spent his life writing, speaking, and debating the truth of the
Christian message. Yet when I was in my upper teens, I had some questions that kind
of troubled me that seemed more pertinent in my life than ever before.
Questions like, how do I really know that Christianity is true?
What if I was born in a different family or in a different culture, would I still
believe the Christian message? What if my beliefs are false?
I decided it was time to share my doubts and my questions with my father, not
knowing how he would respond. After all, he spent his life teaching the
Christian message to others. We were up in the mountains at a small coffee shop and
I remember leaning into my dad and saying, Dad, I want to know what's true.
but I don't know that I'm convinced that Christianity is true and he instantly
looked right back at me he goes son I think that's great and for a second I said
wait a minute dad did you hear what I just said I'm doubting Christianity and he
said I did hear you, son and I think this is good because you can't live your life
based on my convictions you have to come to a point where you know and believe
that christianity is true for yourself he said don't rebel just for the sake of
rebelling so many young people growing up reject what their parents taught them just
out of spite he said if you walk away only do so because you're convinced that
christianity is not true and no matter what you decide you need to know that your
mom and i will always love you doubts and questions are not bad whenever
my students come up to me and say hey Mr.
McDowell I've got some questions and doubts I always respond by saying that's
fantastic I'm so glad you're asking these questions now that's not the typical
response that they expect because sometimes we think that asking questions and
doubting God and His Word can be bad but that's not always the case you see
doubts can be good if we see them as opportunities to go deeper in our faith
it's not doubts that are bad it's unexpressed doubts that can be bad.
You see, it's not doubts that are corrosive to faith.
It's when we have doubts and we don't seek answers.
So if you have doubts about your faith, the first thing to do is to just share them
with somebody and start the conversation.
There are a variety of reasons that might motivate someone to have questions and
doubts. some can certainly be intellectual but I'm convinced that more
often than not the source of a doubt the heart of a doubt comes from emotional
relational or moral reasons consider a couple stories that might help
first I met a young man while speaking at a conference in Chicago and when I was
done he came up to me said hey can we go outside and talk a little further i've got
some questions for you some doubts about my faith i said sure so he went outside and
he had some questions about whether jesus could really be god he had questions about
other religions and after doing my best to answer his questions i sensed that
something deeper was going on i said something to the effect of you know i'm
answering your questions but i think something else is going on with you what is it
and essentially came out he admitted he said you know what i was raised in the
christian faith but i'm just about to graduate from high school, I'm heading
to college and I've joined a fraternity.
I just want to have some fun. And then it hit me.
Although he raised intellectual questions and challenges to the faith, that wasn't
the heart of his doubt. The heart of his doubts were moral.
He wanted to live a certain way and saw his Christian beliefs as getting in the way
of what he thought would be the most fun.
Second, our relationships can deeply affect the way we relate to God.
Take my father for example he had a distant and a drunk father so he would hear
people say things like hey you have a heavenly father who loves you my dad but think
wait a minute father equals hurt and distance and pain why would I want a
Heavenly Father when it just brings more pain?
You see the reality is our relationships, especially our broken relationships,
can drive questions and doubts about God.
An important question we really need to ask ourselves is, how have our
relationships, the ones that have been good and the ones that have failed, affected
the way we view and relate to God?
For many people, the experience...
Hang on, I gotta deal with this.
People who go through doubts will often describe it as if the ground is crumbling
beneath them, or they're fumbling around in the dark.
The experience of doubts can be very painful and can bring up a lot of fears.
That's why one of the place to begin with is to really identify what's at the heart,
what's at the source of my doubts.
And this requires a lot of searching.
Surprisingly, one of the most prominent examples of doubt in the Bible comes from
John the Baptist, the prophesied forerunner of Christ the Messiah.
Herod had John the Baptist arrested, thrown in prison and he sends his disciples to
Jesus to ask him, are you the one or should we expect another?
Well the question is why did John the Baptist have questions and doubts at this
point in his life? And the answer is because he was alone and he was suffering.
Loneliness and pain are common reasons why people have questions and doubts about
God.
Jesus's response is powerful. He doesn't scold John.
He doesn't chastise him. He doesn't show disappointment in John for having questions
and doubts. Rather, he gives John evidence.
In Luke 7:22 through 23, it describes how Jesus says to his
disciples, go back and tell John what you have seen and what you have heard.
The deaf hear, the blind see, the lame walk, and the dead
live again, and the poor have the good news preached to them.
So what does this tell us? Well, for one thing, it tells that doubts are a normal
and natural part of life. All of us should expect to have questions at some
point in our journey of faith. In fact, even the apostles had doubts.
It says in Matthew 28 that they worshiped Jesus as God and yet some of them
doubted. Can you imagine that? The very people who saw the risen
Jesus had doubts. If John the Baptist and the apostles had doubts,
you better believe that some of us, if not most of us, will have doubts at some
point in our life. That's why I believe that Jude 22 says to have mercy on those who
doubt.
Doubt is not the opposite of faith.
In fact, doubt can often serve as the basis for developing a more robust
faith. The key is to identify what is the source of the doubt.
If your doubts are emotional you might need to find and experience some emotional
healing. If your doubts are relational, you might need to restore some broken
relationships. And if your doubts are intellectual, you need to find some answers to
your questions. You see, doubt is not necessarily corrosive to faith, but can be the
opportunity to develop a deeper and a lasting faith.